Speaker 1: Donald Trump wasted almost no time
in attacking Ron DeSantis after Desantis's big
win in the state of Florida. And Trump is also
going after the media over an election disaster
that he brought on himself. There's a good
article in The New York Times called Trump
Under Fire From Within Republican Party After
the midterms. A longtime adviser said Republicans
have followed Donald Trump off the side of
a cliff. Trump flipped out on Truth Social,
which he also calls truth essential.
Growth essential because, as you know,
Trump not only has gotten his own name wrong,
he's gotten the name of his own social media
platform wrong as well. Check out some of these
posts on Troth quote. While in certain ways,
yesterday's election was somewhat disappointing,
from my personal standpoint, it was a very big
victory. It's all about him 219 wins and 16
losses in the general. Who has ever done better
than that? Remember, I don't know how many
times I have to tell you this. I know Trump
and the Republicans are refusing to accept it.
He mostly endorsed incumbents. And Republican
nominees in easy red districts where whoever is
the Republican nominee, they're going to win. You
can run up the score very easily. The 16 losses
are consequential. Control of the Senate hinges on
those 16 losses. Control of the election systems
by governors and secretaries of state and 2024
hinges on those losses. But Trump wants them as
2 to 19 and 16. Okay, here's where it gets very
ugly very quickly. Trump in his next post saying,
quote, Now that the election in Florida is over
and everything went quite well, shouldn't
it be said that in 2020 I got 1.1 million
more votes in Florida than Ron DeSantis got this
year? 5.7 million to 4.6 million. Just asking,
there is one interpretation of this truth. And it
is that Trump is realizing. The energy is getting
behind DeSantis. The strength of the Republican
electorate is shifting like a storm coming in
and changing the direction of the wind towards
Ron DeSantis. And so he immediately needs to
make the case. I'm stronger than DeSantis, even in
Florida. Now, if we want to take this seriously,
you have to remember turnout is lower in midterms,
and gubernatorial elections that coincide with a
midterm rather than a general election tend to
have lower turnout. Is there maybe something to
the claim that Florida would prefer Trump over to
Santos in a presidential race? Sure. I don't know.
I'm not taking a position on that. I don't know
if a primary in the Republican Party in Florida
were held today, whether it would be DeSantis or
Trump, I don't know that. But this is already a
full frontal attack on Ron DeSantis. Trump is
reportedly seething about what's going on with
Florida. He didn't even invite Ron DeSantis
to his rally on Sunday, choosing instead only
to have Marco Rubio there. He did mention, Yeah,
yeah, vote for Ron DeSantis. But it is very clear
that Trump is furious with the Santos. Another one
of these truths. Trump then going after the media.
Remember it's me, me, me. DeSantis bad media. Bad.
Typical narcissist. Trump says, quote, Incredible
how dishonest the fake news media is. The failing
New York Times has gone crazy. So many of the
people i capital e endorsed went on to victory
on tuesday night. Nobody was even close and they
literally make up a story refusing to write the
facts and only quoting enemies and losers. Almost
all of the people I endorsed won. Yet if you read
the story from two Trump hating writers who only
do as they are told, you would not even recognize
the truth. They truly are the enemy of the people.
Again, remember the articles recognize that when
it came to the critical, consequential races Trump
endorsed, mostly people who lost in the critical
would make a difference races. And then Trump
again restating, quote, 219 wins against 16 losses
in the general election. And yet the fake news
rates only unrecognizable junk. No wonder
they are all doing so badly. This is an
absurd framing. Look at all of the people Trump
endorsed who lost as Fetterman Dixon. John Gibbs
lost. Remember when I interviewed him, he was
defeated. J.R. Maju Ski lost. Thank goodness
the 2018 midterms under Trump were not good for
Republicans. The 2020 presidential was lost,
and then they lost everything. Disaster in
2022. So now what are Republicans ready to
say bye bye to Donald Trump? Or are they going to
try it again in 2024? Let me know what you think.